hi nest naka and mr. Beman 3484 I've
gotta wonder who the previous 3483
misters been our but in any case I both
of you got together to ask unemployment
rates are rising one of the main reasons
is because technology is replacing labor
how can we solve the unemployment crisis
and improve the standards of living of
workers when there's rapid growth in
technology use now I confess I'm a bit
of a fan of technology all else equal i
enjoyed gadgets in my personal life and
i see the ways in which information
technology such as what we're using
right now to have this conversation of
sorts is improving the world but it's
also true that technology means you can
do things more efficiently in places and
you can with people and what to do about
that well Isaac Asimov I think tried to
answer it pithily the famous author once
said that what was it he said any job
that a robot can do is beneath the
dignity of a human to do I'm not sure I
actually agree with that there's plenty
of things of robots can do that are fun
to do in fulfilling but when we think
about jobs I think we should be thinking
about fulfilling jobs not just the jobs
that happen to be there and it may well
be that the ones that technology is
displacing are ones where who knows how
fulfilling they were um I'm interested
in ways of technology of course and
create jobs and not just jobs around
making the technology or consuming it
but jobs over technology so for example
there's something called sama source
sama source org is one of several
organizations that tries to find out
micro labor through technology so their
model case is somebody in a refugee camp
can with a mobile phone and a little bit
of connectivity be given tasks to do
whether it's labeling images or maybe
translating some sentences or something
then pay them a penny a pop and they
actually earn money doing it and at the
same time those tasks get done in the
world that's an example of a micro
market how fulfilling this is one other
question but a micro market being opened
up thanks to technology we know these
ships are coming there's going to be
displacement I don't think anybody can
predict whether technologies into more
jobs or fewer jobs
given location I don't know it's kind of
like as universe ultimately expanding or
contracting but the ways in which
technology facilitate better life's
lower prices that means that people are
able to do more and the hope is the
things they end up choosing to do will
be things that maybe computers can't yet
do and that others will be willing to
pay for a bit of a rambling answer but
my best cut at it and very pleased to
have met you and there's a way to get
response fact I will look for anything
right